foreign
[Music]
election system which is now under
coordinated assault and Siege this is
the 11th Rico indictment we followed the
same process we look at the facts we
look at the law and we bring charges
[Music]
if you count the legal votes I easily
win
[Music]
Ricoh statute is a way of incorporating
a number of defendants and a number of
seemingly different crimes into the same
count as an indictment so that you can
prosecute the entire scheme as opposed
to individual defendants or individual
charges
thank you
I think this is a persecution of a
political opponent this was never
supposed to happen in America
[Music]
instruments leading by very very
substantial number
foreign
[Music]